so right now there is an all time
historic record high in terms of the
number of people outside of the
workforce ninety five point three
million people are outside of the
workforce under Donald Trump now this
might sound weird right because we keep
hearing that the unemployment rate is
down and we're seeing sort of steady job
creation Alby it may be a little below
expectations how could it be that we
have this ninety five point three
million number in terms of people out of
work under Trump a record especially
when under Obama it was the only thing
we would hear about from Republicans
every time we had good economic news
under President Obama we'd hear on Fox
News and from other right-wing media
record number of people out of the labor
force and that's exactly the point of
the story that number was deceptive
under Obama and it's deceptive under
Trump but you only heard it from
right-wing media under President Barack
Obama and we have the latest data from
the Bureau of Labor Statistics and it is
very clear that the truth is the number
of people out of the workforce is those
who are watching with us can see on this
graph the number of people out of the
workforce has been steadily climbing for
a long time even before Obama was
president right I mean this this graph
goes back to January of 2007 to a full
two years before President Obama took
over but the truth is and I've been
consistent about it this is not a good
evaluation of the economy it's not a
good evaluation under a Democratic
president and it's not a good evaluation
under a Republican president and you
might be saying David explain to me how
can the unemployment rate go down job
creation numbers be positive and yet we
still have a rising number of people not
in the workforce and that's the
conversation you never heard from the
right under Obama I tried to explain
this to the right-wingers and those
insisting on these conspiracy theories
but I'm sure that if you presented these
numbers to the Trump administration now
all of a sudden they would say oh no
that number is misleading and will tell
you exactly why there are signs of
economic prosperity that pull people out
of the labor force and there are signs
of economic downturn that pull people
out of the labor
for so I'll give you some examples right
when you stop looking for work you're no
longer considered unemployed but you
aren't in the labor force anymore either
so you increase the number of people who
are out of the labor force if the
economy is so bad that people can't find
jobs for a long time and they become
discouraged and stop looking for work
they exit the labor force and that would
be an example of when a growing number
of people out of the labor force
indicates a bad economy but here's a
counter example when the economy is good
and people are more employed and earning
more money you have situations were one
of the two people in a relationship
would be able to afford not working
anymore and for example going back to
school or just taking care of the kids
that is an example of a reduction to the
labor force but it's because the economy
is doing well that they can afford to
get out of the labor force another
example full-time undergraduate college
students are part of what the labor
force measures if you're in college and
you're not working you're out of the
labor force you're one of those
ninety-five point three million the
problem is that if the economy is better
you were more likely to be able to
afford just to go to school full-time
and not have to work in other words if
your parents for example are doing
better economically because they're both
employed in a strong economy you as a
college student don't have to work it's
because the economy is better that
you're not working but you're adding to
the number of people out of the
workforce see where I'm going with this
the labor force numbers include retirees
when the economy is better more people
can afford to retire why would we say
that that's a bad sign for the economy
and lastly when you have a bigger and
bigger population like the US has even
if you hold the percentage of the
country that's out of the of the labor
force even over time because our
population grows you would have more and
more people nominally in raw numbers
outside of the labor force so we have to
understand how these numbers are created
because neither party will consistently
tell us the truth they'll select
we either give or withhold information
about the labor force participation rate
and use those numbers to their advantage
and something that has been used it was
used for eight years to slam President
Obama during really a pretty good
economy it no longer matters because
Trump is President of the United States
it's sort of like the debt under
Republicans under Obama the only issue
is the debt even though he reduced the
deficit an under Trump tax plan health
plan that will blow up the deficit but
all of a sudden Republicans don't care
about that understand the numbers to
understand why it's so deceptive the
video you just watched was made possible
by support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as $1 per
month and every dollar helps to support
the work that we're doing particularly
in light of the YouTube ad boycott which
has been really bad